first of all i want to start by saying
uh congratulations on this movie because
it is so good
and you guys are both so good in it but
i am curious if you both
took this role solely to get treated
better at disneyland and disney world
i mean that was definitely in mind when
we took the part for sure
um i mean it's really cool to think that
like
and when when luca comes out there could
be like
like i guess maybe like people dressed
in luca costumes
like just as sea monsters and stuff and
like those those um
costumes i think that'd be really really
cool that'd be crazy
right so you both agree you took it
solely to be treated better at
disneyland
yeah absolutely only reason we did it
for sure
i've been asking everybody this uh in
the last year uh what tv series would
each of you like to guest star on
career enthusiasm
delorean 100 got it
oh yeah you know you have a connection
to disney now i'm just going to throw
that out
what movie or movies do you think you've
seen the most
oh i've watched good fellas
almost probably a hundred times i'm not
even kidding
that that might be my favorite film
actually yeah me too
yeah it's fantastic also indiana jones
all those movies i've seen
countless times as well for me i mean
it's kind of the same but like
i'm a big star wars fan whoa i mean i
got some pretty cool stuff
but uh yeah have you have you been to
the new
star wars land at disneyland yeah i did
i i did like the custom lightsaber thing
that was really really cool
well you got a custom lightsaber yeah
it's really awesome it's like
you go in there you build your own and
there's like a crystal too that you put
in like can be different color
it's really cool dude i'm so jealous
that's so sick
right well bro i mean we'll probably go
sometime disneyland to just to pronounce
this
let's do that i was gonna say i mean if
this is
anyway i can only imagine the next time
you guys go there oh line
what line yeah exactly i think a lot of
people who are going to watch this
interview might not know
everything that goes on behind the
scenes of making an animated movie
so maybe what surprised you both about
making luca
that perhaps you weren't expecting i
would say i
i probably using actually you know what
i wasn't expecting this cast
if i'm being honest like this cast is
amazing like when i first um started
working on it you know i didn't know
who's gonna be my mom i actually didn't
know who's gonna be alberto and then
you know maya rudolph you know jack
dylan grazer
jim gaffigan is just so cool it's just
an amazing cast
like whoever casted this is it is it go
they did an amazing job
uh jack how much did you pay him to say
that
uh we're not gonna talk about that but
uh
we'll be getting your check in the mail
yeah um
no yeah i'd agree with that the cast is
awesome to work with jacob tremblay the
king of beasts and king of life and king
of king of beasts i like that
um he's the best and uh it's it's it's
been so much fun it's really hard it
really has
what do you think one of the things also
about animated movies is that they can
really
change a lot during the production you
know your character arc
the storyline uh how did this project
change from when you first started
recording to like what people are going
to see
um that's a good question i mean i saw
luca
i'd say the the the character design for
luca changed
not not very significantly but like what
i mean there are some
a few differences you know that that
could
it could have always been like that and
it was just the animation stages made it
look differently
but i think that's probably um what i
saw and change a little bit
originally the turtle was a pelican
not crazy no not crazy it's very kind of
it's not
extremely significant but you know
little thing
what i have to imagine being a part of
something like this
what is it like seeing the finished film
i mean how did it compare to what you
actually thought it would be going in
um oh dude it was it exceeded my
expectations
i mean usually with any pixar movie like
my my i'm
in shock of how beautiful it is but this
one i have to say is so unique
in how it's cinematic like and how and
how it even feels italian and it almost
feels like it's shot
by bertolucci no maybe not burluchi but
fellini maybe sort of
uh or um who's the other guy sir leone
sergio leone anyway um i i really have
to say that it's so beautiful the the
colors the brilliance of
blue and green and red and yellow it's
stunning
yeah i mean he pretty much said it all i
love the the kind of like pastel colors
of of the buildings it literally looks
like you can
i was about to see something really
weird but i was gonna say like it it
feels like if you were to lick the walls
of one of the buildings it tastes like
fruit
that's that's kind of what it looks like
i don't know why i just
uh i got an individual question for each
of you because you're both in
two upcoming things that i'm super
excited about
uh jacob you're playing flounder in the
live-action little mermaid
which i'm so curious about and obviously
i think
this other guy who i'm talking to is in
a shazam sequel
um and i'm also very excited for that so
for both of you what can you tease about
both projects
um i'll go first um working on the film
um has been really awesome everyone
there's so nice like that
it's just so fun to work on a phone like
that um but i really like what they did
with flanders character design i won't
say too much but
it's really cool i have a question about
that actually too
wait with with are you is are you
animated
i mean i don't say too much man okay i'm
gonna let them
film okay okay um
i for uh so it's a great cast we got
helen mirren we got lucy lou we got
the new up-and-coming star rachel zegler
from steven spielberg's west side story
we um and it's a great it's the script
is hilarious
it's funnier than the first one i'd have
to say and and we're getting away with a
lot more this time
um and it's action-packed and it's got
twists and turns and it's super duper
fun
the costume is different no hood sleeper
and the shoe is kind of like iron man's
shoes oh wait
iron man doesn't exist he's iron man
[Laughter]
the we saw the pictures of the new
costume have been hit
online and it looks cool but yeah i am
curious
about the script for the shazam sequel
what your reaction reading it the first
time was like oh
wow it was like oh wow
it totally i think i can say this
because i think that i saw this
oh my god i better not right i don't
want to get you in trouble
i don't want to pull with tom holland
i like how everyone knows he's the one
that screws up
i'll just say that i'm really looking
forward to both but now i'll ask
probably the most important question
jacob you are a big star wars fan
uh yeah i mean i just i just showed you
this guy so i know
so how do you rank the top three movies
in the in the star wars universe what's
number thank you for asking this
question thank you so much for asking
this question i never get asked this so
i really appreciate this
okay i'm gonna go first um empire
strikes back
yes obviously second revenge of the sith
i think anakin's awesome and the fight
at the end is great and
darth vader is so cool um and then third
i think for my third pick i'm going to
go with
i'm gonna go with a new hope
i think the og one you know bro that was
the best
that was the best thank you i'm glad
that you understand
i understand perfectly that's what i
would have said too exactly
i might have said it yeah oh you said
empire strikes back right yeah yeah
for my first kick yeah that's perfect
then yes yeah i have so much to say to
this
i will just say for the next time um you
guys have a great day
i think it's also the age when you see a
movie it dictates but empire strikes
back as most people's
top and same with me yeah okay yeah that
makes sense
you guys have a fantastic day thank you
so much for talking that was really fun